[Music]
thank you
is that gonna fit everyone easily 12
customers total how do they turn a
profit 12.50 ahead that's how what are
we eating a Rolex
it's classics
you have to try the mouse feel of the
minionette please don't say mouthful
tonight will be Madness
welcome
we'll Endeavor to make your evening as
pleasant as possible
welcome to Hawthorne
Here We are family
we Harvest we ferment we Jam
wait gel we gel
he's not just a chef he's a Storyteller
the game is trying to guess what the
overarching theme of the entire meal is
going to be
you won't know till the end
who are you I
am Marco
why do you care I have to know if you're
with us or with them this
is the pictures
how do they get these it's not good this
entire evening
we're leaving now has been painstakingly
planned
[Music]
this is real isn't it what the hell is
going on
we now offer you a 45 second Head Start
okay 45 seconds starts now
this is what you're paying for
eign
[Music]
you told them it was my birthday
seemed funny about three hours ago
[Music]
my baby
[Music]
rescued from a river
your new baby brother Moses
[Music]
for long
lost by royalty you are not a prince of
Egypt what did you say everything I
am's a lie you are our son I can't stay
here any longer Moses please
goodbye brother the truth gave him the
courage
to do the impossible
abandon this futile Mission Moses
DreamWorks Pictures presents
story for our time
[Music]
a celebration of the human spirit
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
that's what I'm good at not the work not
the work
the presentation
kielbasa sausage Cheese's Beluga caviar
and of course who could live without
German cigarettes as many as you can
find
it's more fresh fruit
the real Rarities oranges lemons
pineapples I need several boxes of cumin
cigars the best and dark on sweetened
chocolate not in the shape of
ladyfingers the chunk of chocolate
because my hands you sample of wine
tastings 900 no mega 10 for Wednesday
all this stuff here goes to Magic
distract me
I lost the worker
expect to be commented he's on the list
[Music]
I woke up from a dream this morning
I was broke and sharing a room with 12
people want to start huh
do you have any questions sir
what's your name
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I have to find every rack better
[Music]
[Music]
presents the exciting quiz program 21.
give me the name of the explorer who
discovered Mozambique
Vasco de Gama correct for 10 points
Temple is an underdog no people root for
that there wasn't a very terrific have
you seen the ratings I'd like you to
meet next week's Challenger Charles Van
Doren hello how much they pay
instructors up at Columbia 86 a week do
you have any idea how much Bozo the
Clown makes
got to be James J Braddock correct you
have 21. this guy a natural or what he's
a natural twenty thousand dollars
what if we would ask you questions that
you know well I think I'd really rather
try to beat him honestly just an idea
was that part of the test
[Music]
yes I know his name halek General H.W
Hallock you have 21
. awesomely amazing facts these guys
have at their fingertips it's been nine
weeks now and you've won how much and 93
thousand dollars
sir I smell something
that little rocks in your living room is
plugged into something crooked
you lose when I tell you to lose now I'm
supposed to take a dive you know you got
these crackpots coming out of the
woodwork you don't have a shred of
concrete evidence
young man I am the President of the
National Broadcasting Company I have you
and why are you the one that's sweating
Charles Van Doren hails from one of the
most prominent intellectual families in
this country I'm a Witch Hunt he thinks
21 is Rick
Asia
[Music]
foreign
you should see the letters I get kids
are excited about learning
I said a real example for all us boys to
look up to
[Music]
sign the statement
[Music]
if someone offered you all this money
would you do it no and I would
Professor I'm sorry I'm going to have to
ask for your answer
[Music]
same rank serial number sorry I can't
help you
I think I was a pilot
[Music]
anybody remotely foreign
to keep me alive
because I'm a nurse
anybody she ever loves tends to dial her
ask your Saint who he's killed
you're in love with them aren't you
there the heart is an organ of Fire
I believe
[Music]
back for me I promise I'll come back for
you
hurry be safe
be strong
Harry Potter
[Music]
you have fought valiantly
now join me and confront your fate
you've kept him alive so they can die at
the proper moment bring it to me
let's find out where he is
now
[Music]
[Music]
the boundaries protect us
I have to go back haven't I it's a
suicide mission
boy who knew
come to die
tell them how it happened that night how
you looked him in the eye a man who
trusted you and killed him
I never wanted any of you to die for me
you'll stay with me always until the end
[Music]
let's finish this the way we started
forget about
only I can live forever
thank you
it's gone
you better know what's at stake here
there isn't much Road left take the
bloody shot
what do you say about a man like that
three months ago you lost the drive
containing the identity of every agent
embedded in Terrorist organizations
across the globe
007 reporting for Duty where the hell
have you been enjoying death
I only have one question why not stay
dead there's no shame in saying you've
lost a step
they weren't targeting her
they wanted her to see it welcome to the
new MI6
I'm a quartermaster you must be joking
both the PPKs nine millimeter short it's
been coded to your palm print so only
you can fire it less of a random killing
machine more of a personal statement
Q
007
I want to meet your employer how much do
you know about fear
s or not like this
not like
just look at you chasing spies England
and my six
she send you after me know when you're
not ready know when you would likely die
mommy was very bad
the two survivors this is what she made
us everybody needs a hobby so what's
yours
Resurrection
[Music]
foreign
creature is a profound secret and
mystery to every other
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you thank you Mr Dickens it was
remarkable it was yes I am told these
readings double tails you are an admirer
of my husband's work Miss Ellen of
course
is a fiction designed to entertain
surely it's more than that it changes us
my writing is ferocious I fight not to
be distracted
constellation
constantly watched life is nothing
without good company
[Music]
father Charlie what are you doing here
Paul gossip in the London diary who
cannot keep her a secret yes I can
do you love him he's married that has
not stopped him falling in love with you
and watch you together you see him he
sees you what more does one want in life
his honorable man but he cannot marry me
no he cannot
you are part of my existence part of a
little good in me part of the evil there
is an insanity to his behavior
you have a choice you could find the
difference a different life what
different life what life is there for me
I know what I have done Nelly Nelly
what is it that we are
[Music]
why do you want to be a lobby boy
who wouldn't at the Grand budapester and
so my life began Junior lobby boy in
training under the strict command of Mr
Gustav H many of the hotel's most valued
and distinguished guests came for him I
love you I love you she was dynamite in
the sack by the way she was 84. I've had
older this was also when I met Agatha
she's Charming she's so Charming is he
flirting with you yes I approve of this
Union I became his pupil and he was to
be my counselor and guardian the police
are here
tell them I'll be right there
she's been murdered and you think I did
it
hey
you're looking so well darling you
really are I don't know what sort of
cream they've put on you down at the
morgue but I want some this is Madame
D's last will and testament
painting known as boy with apple wow
what
I'm afraid that's me darling
if I learned you have a once laid a
finger on my mother's body living more
dead I go to bed with all my friends
[Music]
we need to make a plan for your survival
hide this it's encode and you might need
a magnifying glass to read it but it
tells you exactly where and how to find
boy with apple I'm a baker I'm not a
fence if that's the term
[Music]
I want roadblocks at every Junction for
50 kilometers I want rail blocks at
every train station for 100 kilometers
get in I want 50 men and 10 Bloodhounds
ready in five minutes
[Music]
do God arrest him simply because he's a
bloody immigrant take your hands off my
lobby boy
[Music]
have you ever been questioned by the
authorities yes on one occasion I was
arrested and tortured by the rebel
militia after the desert Uprising right
well you know the drill then zip it
[Music]
my flock
this will not be a War of Heroes
Nations will Slaughter each other while
we get rich
this is going to be fun
thank you
you cannot keep me locked away as the
world Burns
the truth is the world is ruled
by corruption and greed we must do
something certainly
[Music]
we are the First Independent
intelligence agency
refined but brutal
civilized but merciless
welcome to the club very clever
it's time to pour fuel
on the Fire
of Revolution yes my shepherd
welcome English man
Rasputin your reputation precedes you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
why is it that boys are always so messy
[Music]
[Music]